okay  go ahead and have a seat  [Music]  my name is mark s i'm helly r my name is  irving b my name is dylan g and i have  of my own free accord elected to undergo  the procedure known as severance  awesome  i give consent for the lumen corporation  and it's a good corporation to sever my  memories between my work life  and my personal life  i acknowledge that once the procedure is  complete  i will be unable to access my personal  memories whilst on lumens severed floor  nor will i retain work memories when i  return home at the end of the day  i am aware that this alteration is  comprehensive and irreversible  okay  that's a wrap  [Music]  um  open or closed  both  [Music]  you